this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisement yeah they do every
little thing you think that's me every
little singing you thing that to me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'd be fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all let's record a podcast hello
everybody my name is Joshua fields
Millburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalist
[Applause]
Wow so we have a very special guest here
tonight and so what we're going to do is
we're going to answer some of your
questions were going to bring him out in
a second and then thank you so much for
being here tonight you're welcome we
have a special guest here he is an
author and he is also a talented
podcaster I'm proud to be able to call
him a friend
he's also I think he's literally the
fittest and healthiest person that I
know ladies and gentlemen let's welcome
to the stage mr. rich roll yeah so rich
you just turned 50 and I am yeah man I
would look like that when I'm sitting I
want to look like that when I'm 20 but
but so there's this weird thing like I
was I was thinking about earlier today I
was walking around like there's so many
things that I could say about rich right
now and we're going to we're in this
moment in time well it's like when you
meet someone new what's one of the first
things I ask you what do you do for
words that like just kill any
conversation right because then you're
like well well the title on my business
card says this and and then you spend 15
minutes talking about what you do to
earn a living and there's nothing wrong
with that we all have to earn a paycheck
or money to pay the bills right but I
found a long time ago rich I found that
I changed that question back when I was
in the corporate world people would come
up to me and I hadn't had an impressive
answer to that question as you used to
as well right so when someone would come
up to me and say what do you do I would
have the Director of Operations for 150
retail stores and
for this company which I know it's
really ironic now with the minimalism
thing and retail stores
but it was what I did at the time and
then I would say what do you do and and
really it was like well what is your job
title but the truth is that question is
really really broad question I mean that
there are so many things well I like to
take long walks on the beach and I drink
water I go to concerts I listen to
podcast what do you mean what do I do
oh you're saying where do I work how
much money do I earn so you can compare
you to me on the socio-economic ladder
so rich I won't be asking you that today
thank but what I did with that
experiment is I would say when someone
asked me what you do I say I'm really
passionate about writing and then I
would say that that would usually change
the trajectory of the question because
I'd say what are you passionate about so
so rich I guess my question is instead
of saying what do you do what I'm going
to ask you is what are you passionate
about and how did you get from where you
were what was the inciting incident or
incident that got you to where you are
right now you're throwing me a softball
buckling it's like a heavy loss they
kick things off yeah man I am I am
passionate about living purposefully
that's what's meaningful to me how to
live authentically how to access and
exude your best most authentic self I
guess to put a pithy phrase to it and
like yourselves I have my own version of
your story I'm a recovering corporate
attorney I've had a couple inciting
incidents along my journey to being able
to have the privilege of sitting up here
with you guys you know it started with
it started with a bout with alcoholism
that was an inciting incident then
getting sober and started to reconfigure
my life around spiritual principles as
opposed to material principle and you
guys sober early 30th 31 yeah 31 and in
the wake of spending 100 days in rehab
which is a long time together
I needed it at first I threw all of
those addictive alcoholic tendencies
into my work into my profession because
I was somebody who had demonstrated a
lot of potential as a young person and
I'd squandered that as a result of my
drinking and using and I became very
determined to get that back to repair my
relationships to become an upstanding
citizen and professional and what that
meant in my life at that time was you
know making partner at my law firm and
putting in those 80 to 90 hour weeks and
doing the things that you know you guys
spoke about earlier buying the fancy car
and spending money that I didn't have
and realizing very slowly that this was
widening the gap between my life
satisfaction quotient and you know what
I was aiming for and not meeting up to
you know that standard that I'd set for
myself this idea of the American dream
that I premise my entire life on go to
you know work hard get good grades get
into the best college getting in the
best grad school get the best job you
know show up early work late all that
stuff and so by the time I was 39 I had
all those things you know I had a really
nice car I you know I had a lot of a lot
of stuff a lot of stuff and I had this
existential crisis about how I was
living because I wasn't taking care of
myself physically that existential
crisis about what is my purpose what am
I doing here
but it up against a health scare because
I put on 50 pounds I was a junk food
addict I was stressed out I was
depressed I was essentially hurtling
into middle-age on a crash course with
chronic lifestyle elements and so the
real inciting incident that changed my
life happened shortly before my 40th
birthday when I was walking up a simple
flight of stairs up to my bedroom late
one night after coming home late from
work and having to pause halfway up a
simple flight of stairs like winded out
of breath tightness in my chest like
buckled over and really afraid that I
was at
of having heart attack I was 39 and I
had been you know a world ranked swimmer
and cause like I was an athlete you know
and so that was a real awakening moment
for me and it was very similar to the
moment that I decided I was going to go
to rehab you know and in it and it sort
of conjured up that idea of how powerful
these these inciting incidents can be
how powerful these moments are that when
you make a decision in that moment how
profoundly it can change your life and
because that had happened with me
getting sober I realized that once again
I was being visited by one of those
moments and that I had an opportunity to
act and I knew that if I acted
immediately deliberately specifically
that I could change my life and and
that's exactly what I did and that what
kind of changes did you make from from
that point there there were some
significant changes yeah if you google
me and you read online stories about
about this change in my life it looks
like it all happened you know overnight
and it wasn't like that it was a number
of years I mean it started with diet I
slowly progressed adopting a plant-based
diet a vegan diet yeah buddy
who here is vegan we got vegans in the
house yeah awesome going plant-based
revitalized my health it got me
interested in health and fitness and
exercise once again I actually wanted to
move my body and and connect with that
physical part of who I am and and and
that really brought a lot of joy into my
life it was something that I had had
brought me so much happiness as a young
person but I put so much distance
between myself and that for so many
years so you know nutrition plant-based
diet exercising Fitness one thing led to
another and then you know a couple years
later I found myself interested in the
world of ultra endurance sports because
I changed my life so profoundly in a
relatively short period of time I
started thinking a lot about potential
you know by making a few simple changes
in my life I was able to access
potential that I didn't even know that I
and so I started to think well what
where else am I overlooking areas of
self-development
where are my hidden reservoirs of
potential that I haven't tapped into yet
and ultra endurance sports seem like a
really cool template for exploring that
not just physically but also mentally
emotionally and spiritually you know I'm
really inspired by you know I'm inspired
by your story but I'm inspired by more
by your actions today like literally
today I see a tweet from him it got up
to six and then went you know swimming I
don't know how far you swam but it was
quite a few miles but it's what you're
preparing for and you know I see this
and I'm like I got up early to I got up
at 5:00 a.m. at the gym but I'm like man
I could be doing doing so much so much
more what drives you at this point I
mean I think in order to answer that you
have to reframe it like a lot of people
look at at the training that I do right
now and I think it's that's it sounds
horrible but it's actually what I enjoy
doing like given the choice this is if I
have free time this is what I prefer to
do this is how I prefer to spend my time
and that's not necessarily connected to
me making a dollar or you know a of
improving my career professionally or
anything like that it's just this is who
I am you know it's a natural extension
of my authentic self so when you asked
me initially at the outset of our
conversation you know what what is what
what are you most passionate about it is
living authentically and so when I began
this journey and started training for
these crazy ultra-endurance right I mean
people thought I was insane you know I
was supposed to be you know trying to
make partner law for our minim and you
know instead I was spending all my time
trying to make no sense at all but I
just knew like my heart was telling me
to do this and for some reason I felt
this pull and I knew that pole was pure
and that it was real and if I followed
that thread even though it defied logic
that I would find the answers that I was
seeking through that
and it took many years and it was
painful it was very much the Warriors
path but by sort of burning in those
flames I was able to come out the other
side and craft this new life that that's
really founded upon you know seeking out
and pursuing and exuding and sharing
these ideas of how to live authentically
how to live purposefully and
intentionally and so you you know a
great podcast by the way it's called the
rich world podcast to those of you
running uninformed getting foreign it's
great podcast one fan over here yeah but
they really love you yet but I what what
made you dive into that and the reason I
asked the question is because you are a
phenomenal interviewer I we we sat down
on a ledge fall and like I was staying
in a little Airbnb in West Hollywood I
was up in LA for a week and you came
over and you had like this whole setup
and and we just had like just a genuine
conversation there for a couple hours
and what I guess what compels you to to
do the podcast the way you do it and and
and and how how the hell are you such a
good conversationalist when you sit
behind the microphone I appreciate the
kind words well it takes two to tango
you are an amazing person to speak to so
the conversation was easy for me the
only thing missing from that
conversation was Bryan currently had
more important things to do that day but
thank you for that I started the podcast
in 2012 I fell in love with the medium
when I was training for these ultra
endurance races because I would put in
training days like eight hours on the
bike and you can't listen to music for
that long right and I started listening
to audiobooks and I started falling in
love with podcasts and so I was at first
of all I was a fan of the medium and
then I wrote a book that came out in
2012 called finding ultra it's a memoir
it's my story and in the wake of that
book being released
I thought well what's the next thing
like how can I continue the conversation
that was begun in this book which is
very much about addiction and recovery
and sobriety and diet and fitness and
wellness and you know living
authentically and I thought well maybe
I'll take a crack at a podcast so in
2012 to start a podcast I mean I wasn't
an early adopter because the medium had
been around really since around I guess
2006 or so is when it kind of you know
premiered on iTunes but in 2012 it
wasn't cool to have a podcast and I
noticed that in the health space there
wasn't really that many people who were
doing anything of high caliber and I
wanted to contribute to that and and
bring you know not only my experience
but be able to put a microphone in front
of people that I had had the privilege
of encountering on my journey to help
amplify their voice and I think the sort
of primary theme of my show or like how
I go into each of these conversations
it's not about extracting information
from the guests that's sort of a
tangential benefit but really my goal is
to be able to connect with them like to
be able to have an honest authentic I
know that words getting thrown bandied
around pretty cavalierly but to really
have an authentic connection with the
person that I'm speaking to and to trust
that if I can do that then the
information will flow but if you can
connect with somebody in a really
fundamental honest way that's where the
magic happens so instead of planning out
how I want it to go to do to show up and
be present and to listen most people
don't listen you know I mean they have
their ten questions they want to ask as
soon as you answer it they say awesome
and then they ask the next question what
would happen if you actually listen to
what the person is saying to you
the next question is always baked into
that if you're paying attention so so
when I sat down with you in that little
Airbnb it was like a little rickety
table and it was it was evident to me
that you were listening but not it
wasn't just the head knob and the sort
of passive passive listen it was it was
engaged and what I the word you use was
authenticity and for me that's like the
one thing you actually can't affect
right you can't pretend to be authentic
because by definition if you're being
authentic then then you're being
authentic right and and so the thing
that I felt there and I felt at ease
which is not something that I feel very
often during an interview I soon as you
shovel microphone in front of my face I
feel like the biggest mumble mouth in
the world and it was about 15 minutes in
where were just like like I felt like I
was just I had breezed this sigh of
relief so and I see that you do that was
so many of your guests and you have
great guests on from all walks of life
and it all ties back to to living an
intentional life or or just human
well-being in general it doesn't mean
that everyone on your show necessarily
has the same beliefs as you and that's
what's really nice about it is you tend
to get to whatever your core values are
via different beliefs different realms
like if you're getting to a destination
you take a different Road there you know
you can take the Pacific Coast Highway
or you can take you know I five down to
LA eventually you'll get there either
way those are different beliefs but if
you end up with the same spot
those are your values and I find the
conversations you have on your podcast
do that so I want to acknowledge you for
that and just say thanks thanks for
great yeah appreciate that thank you and
I think that's because I just I think
it's if I have a strength it's less
about conversational skill than it is
about empathy you know like I try to
cultivate empathy like what would it be
like to walk a mile in this person's
shoes and the more I can expand that
empathetic impulse then that creates
comfort in the guest and a lot
the magic to percolate up well before we
dive into some questions we do have a
microphone down here somewhere oh it's
right there you're welcome to come up
now so after the event Ryan and I do
hubs and pictures a lot of stuff and
we'd love to hug all 600 of you or
however many people were here but we
can't answer everyone's questions so now
is the time for questions if you have a
question come on up we'll do our best to
to answer it all three of us do I see a
line I just Eliza is it this is my
question
Oh awesome Beauty had people all right
cool well let's get started let's dive
in my gosh hi Ryan
and hi rich nice to meet you how's your
name is my name is Gary Gary nice smile
Gary that's a that's a good woman thank
you
so I didn't get as smart as you guys as
early as you guys but in eight weeks I
am leaving my corporate job
congratulations and I want to thank you
guys what do you do I'm the director of
up now I am a buyer for a chain of 260
stores Oh way to one-up me
congratulations brother I'm proud of
great man thank you thank you so I want
to thank you guys first of all for
providing a template and guidance as I
try to decide what's next what's my
encore career and I'm going to read this
I'm tempted to piggyback onto your value
but feel that I really should go through
my own process of examination you often
mention the importance of being clear on
your values and beliefs
can you discuss the process you use to
develop and clarify your five
foundational values what are the
questions that you ask or the resources
that you reference to facilitate that
process yeah that might be an essay it
might not be a podrace much-enduring
that's great
so so let's talk about values real quick
since we touched on that just for a
second I think there are four different
types of values right so you have these
these foundational values and what Ryan
and I wrote about in our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life which
is available afterward in the Lavi
no seriously is it I mean yeah we do
have books out there if you can't afford
one for whatever reason we're happy to
buy you a copy as well so if you want
one please pick it up it's on us if you
can't if you can't afford it but if you
do buy one it goes to one of our
favorite charities it's to prepare our
smashed window because a bunch of our
shift got stolen today thanks average
let's go ice alright I was so honored to
have our windows smashed in San
Francisco I still freaking love this
city
there are so many cars on that Street
they chose ours so Ryan and I identify
once we got the stuff out of the way we
started asking some questions so some of
the questions I talked about earlier
why have I given so much meaning to all
this stuff that was one of the questions
what is truly important in my life who
is the person I want to become why have
I been so discontented that one was
important the discontented one because I
made me think like what what is making
me anxious what is making me overwhelm
what is pissing me off so I can do the
opposite of that so I can fix it right
and then you know who's the person I
want to become that's like sort of
looking at a horizon and so like who's
my 40 year old self
what's that person look like not exactly
like that what's the exact recipe what
are my goals that's not what I'm looking
for I'm just looking for an ideal sort
of horizon to travel toward and once I
get there they'll always be a new
horizon the travel tour and then what is
my definition of success and that's
change radically because the old
template was broken for me and it sounds
like that template was broken for you
right because you achieve something you
think well I'm going to be happier I'm
going to feel something and you might
but it's fleeting it lasts you know it's
aims when you buy something at you go
buy something expensive that maybe you
didn't really need or even want that
much you get this little high at the
checkout line but by the time you get
home with the thing and see the receipt
you're like what have I done and and so
once we start asking those questions we
figured out these five higher-order
values or foundational values health
relationships passion or you might call
it creativity growth and contribution
and I find any time I'm feeling
discontented now it's because one of
those buckets is missing somewhere give
you a quick example the last two years
of my life have been two of the best and
two of the most challenging years of my
life at the same time because my I've
had a lot of health issues I've had
some tremendous back problems and crazy
back pain I had some and still do have
I'm repairing my gut I had really bad
gut microbiome issues from long-term
antibiotic use and it really [ __ ] up
my life I mean it really did to the
point there was a point toward the end
of last year I thought I was dying
like I updated my will and Ryan and I
stopped doing the podcast for a month I
stopped doing anything I'm like this
might be it
and and so I had to laser focus on the
health stuff and I still do the reason I
was up at 5:00 a.m. this morning I was
doing an hour and 15 minutes of physical
therapy and went back and so I will do
that make the time for it so those are
those are the five higher-order values
but then beyond that you sort have these
core values and I think those
higher-order values or the foundational
values those foundational values they're
pretty much the same for everyone I
think to a great extent you can add new
ones in there and you can say well no I
don't value and you don't value my
health I mean I think I think those five
are to a certain extent are going to
apply to everyone
what health means to you is going to be
different what health means to rich is
like if I don't run a marathon twice a
day then I'm not healthy
no it's certainly it's certainly going
to be different for come on I'm
projecting my insecurities onto you it's
okay no I I think that I think there's
going to be the same I think the next
level the core values change pretty
dramatically depending on on who you are
and I think there's a list for I think
mine's about 20 I mean things like
freedom or free speech I think you want
to be able to define those with a tweet
figure out what those values are and
it's good to have someone else an
accountability partner or a partner in
fact my partner Rebecca she's here
tonight this is her last night hanging
out on the tour Rebecca
somewhere up there
she has a great website called minimal
wellness a lot of great recipes and well
and she also has the recipe for your
values on there so if you go to minimal
wellness comm slash value she has like a
worksheet that she put together based on
her and I sitting down and sort of going
through our own values one by one and
identifying things like freedom or
autonomy or caring or loving or support
that different values and then defining
those with one sentence and it needs to
be something that's memorable that you
can that you can stick to and you want
to go over I tend to go over that list
once a month and now to re-evaluate it
once a year so those core values are
really important and they'll shift over
time I mean the cool thing about doing
it with a partner is you find that oh
wow yeah you said this is really
valuable and you know what that's
valuable to me too or I wouldn't say it
exactly like this because here's what I
value and it allows you to expand and
solidify your values beyond that I could
give minor values I think that's sort of
this next year and those are things that
add value to your life that aren't
necessary to live a meaningful life but
those really vary dramatically for
different peoples certain hobbies or
things that that are minor values will
absolutely need them but they help out
then you have this fourth layer the
imaginary values and I was spending most
of my time on what I imagined was
valuable
you know incessantly checking Facebook
or email or going bouncing from meeting
to meeting the meeting these were these
imaginary values in my life watching TV
browsing the internet for hours on end
and I have to get that under check
because those were getting in the way of
my my real values and so watch out for
the imaginary values and keep it real
you adding because sometimes those
things are minor values now they'll stop
being valuable to your life and you have
to admit that this is an imaginary value
now I think you can follow that simple
it'll help you out great thank you and I
look forward to visiting minimal
wellness and thank you Becca
thanks for being here here man
I just I'll say just a couple more
things to add what Josh said to really
get to those core values because I mean
I should say with the foundational
values like that's that's where it we
got to start right got to have a good
foundation before you can build up on
that I mean a lot of people might just
be stuck on those foundational values
and eat the question I would start with
is what are my priorities I mean that's
that's what I started with when I was
looking at 80% of my stuff still still
sitting in boxes I'm like standing there
looking at all that stuff and I'm
starting to like play out this narrative
in my head of like what am i doing like
what is why am i living my life and yeah
I explored myself like well you know
maybe one day I'll save up enough money
and he'll retire like age 45
or maybe age 50 or you know I'll retire
early but then I'm looking at tens of
thousands of dollars of stuff that I had
in my living room and then I look at my
bank account hadn't really been saving
anything like not even getting close to
that and then I thought about oh you
know what my health like that that's one
of my priorities to like I'm not healthy
I'm not happy but I was staying out at
the bar till three o'clock in the
morning and then you know I stopped it
in the Midwest you stopped a White
Castle at 3:00 in the morning and then
you know I thought about my
relationships well those are important
if you don't have good people in your
life well then you know what kind of
life are you living I mean you got to
look at who you are it's the five people
you hang out with and it's who you're
you're you know who you look up to and
my mom like she was really important but
I saw her maybe you know six or seven
times a year
she was the half-hour away and so I was
sitting there looking at like wow here
are all these things that are preventing
me from actually putting effort or
taking action on these priorities and
what I realized is that yeah like our
priorities it's not what we say they are
it's what we do so for anyone out there
who is struggling just with those
foundational values like ask yourself
what are your priorities and then look
at how you're spending your time and if
you're not spending your time on those
priorities but they're not really your
priorities and the other thing I'll say
to Gary this man I am so I'm so proud of
you man for starting that you're like oh
you know I didn't I didn't get it smart
and editing it smart as young as you
guys but man there is there is never
it's never too late to start like we
will have it's so true and we will have
um you know in st. Louis we had a unlike
during our 2014 tour we had it was like
an 88 year old grandmother show up and
she was like you know I am I am finally
getting started on on simplifying my
life and I've brought you know my
daughter and my and my grandkids and she
had she heard her grandkid had just had
a kid so the three generations of
daughters there and she was like and I'm
finally starting my journey and I know
that people happen like oh I'm too old
I'm too this round to that and it's too
hard to start well you're right it is
hard to start but you're never too old
to start I mean we had a five-year-old
show up and it was in San Diego and as
I'm walking out to the meet-and-greet
line she's like her parents are like go
on go on and she's like hi I'm five and
I'm like cool she's like I just donated
my clothes you want to talk about
starting young man she's starting
younger than me but how cool is that
like you know five-year-old certain a
young uh my uh my mom she is she's got a
job right now she called me up a couple
weeks ago and she was telling me how
she's saving up to buy an RV so she's
got about a six to eight month plan
where she's like working her butt off
she's saving up money she's going to buy
an RV
she's gonna be 60 soon like well
honestly soon next couple years got oh
geez not listen to this lovey mom um and
and she's gonna buy an RV her plan I'm
not even joking her plan is to just
drive around city to city state to state
doing open mic nights like living his
simple life yeah she's gonna be 60 not
too soon like how awesome is that and
you know what all I can say is like I
love your mom and I will support you
however I want I could probably come up
with some awesome minimalist jokes like
how many minimalist does it take to
screw in a light bulb zero because
minimalist don't own light bulbs right
no so so congratulations man keep up the
great work and you're going to you're
going to be awesome and a real quick
before we move on last question which
let me ask you because clearly you had
two inside answers that there were
almost a decade apart in a way right you
sort of said okay you go to through
recovery and then and then it pings you
over into this corporate hysteria and
then you realize like oh I'm out of
whack on this side how did your values
change throughout that I mean a dozen
years or so that you went through all of
that well I think it it brings up an
interesting question that I was going to
ask you guys because the we know values
and value like your you're constantly
like fielding these questions like you
know should I give away my stuff should
I not and your retort is always like
will does it bring value to your life
right and I've been thinking about that
and the word value is kind of vague
right it's an undefined thing and it's a
very personal it's very personal right
we all have a different version of what
that is
and the word value is also different
from values you know what I mean so
parsing that I think is an individual
journey and in my own case I would say
that my core values you know my fondant
my fundamental values haven't changed
but I would say that my actions have
become more in alignment with those
values over time and again that's been a
very gradual process for me you know
going from the person who's just you
know how am I going to get mine and
everybody else is in my way and you know
they're a threat to me because this is a
zero-sum game going from that like
mentality which I thought you know was
in alignment with my values but of
course was not and led to that
existential crisis so in a way like
competition was an imaginary value for
you back then or winning it with respect
to but it wasn't even winning in a way
it seemed like it was like making sure
other people lost so that you did not I
wouldn't say it went that far with my
job I would say I'm a naturally
competitive person I'm competitive with
myself and that's that's demonstrated
that in athleticism in sports and now
you know you I try to fuel that
competitiveness into you know sort of a
positive Channel you know yeah buddy now
it's all about like how can I help the
most number of people in the most
positive and profound way to catalyze
long-term change in them you know that's
that's like my operating system for how
I approach my career in my life and that
has to spill into you know not just my
professional life but my personal life
my relationship with my wife and my kids
and keeping all of those things in an
appropriate balance so that I can
continue to do what I do so I think that
the biggest shift was going from
somebody who was very out of balance to
somebody who recognizes that I'm
attracted to being out of balance I'm
attracted to extremes fighting that for
a long time saying I should be balanced
and then coming to a realization that
actually there's a lot of strength in my
attraction to these extremes and trying
to figure out a way to not only be okay
with
to accept that as part of who I am but
to find outlets for it that can be
helpful right
the pendulum always swings back you know
I can be I'm out of balance in a day but
over the course of a month or a year you
know make sure that all the important
things in my life are in balance so I
would say that that would be one shift
[Applause]
howdy you might want to move that mic
down just a little bit there you go
all right so you guys talk a lot about
dredging through the drudgery and I want
to know what has helped you in the past
do it or currently to do that yeah what
was it was it Faulkner's that said I
think it may have been that I write only
when I'm inspired and I make sure I'm
inspired every morning at 8:30 a.m. I
mean here's the thing so I've said that
quite a bit with with respect to writing
I teach a writing class online it's
called how to write better org for those
of you interested and I really learned
that I spent most of my twenties
aspiring to write but I didn't do much
writing because I was waited until like
well I was like a list of 15 different
things but as soon as the laundry's
folded and I have my cup of coffee and
oh you know what I forgot to do the
dishes
and so I have all these like this whole
list of things and as soon as I do these
15 things then I'm ready to write and of
course I get 14 of them done and there's
always be the 15 thing and then I would
run out of time and I'll do it tomorrow
right and and of course if you keep that
up long enough you don't actually put in
any work and so I decided the best way
for me to be able to put into work is to
actually do the work and that meant I
had to get rid of those rules instead of
having 15 rules right before I was ready
to write for me it was having one rule I
have to wake up like that was it now if
I could figure out how to write when I'm
asleep then I will be the most efficient
writer ever but until then that's my
only rule and I got rid of the other one
but it doesn't mean that it's always fun
right I'm not always inspired
in fact when I first started writing and
writing seriously it was about 80%
drudgery for that 20% pay off and I used
to mistake that as not being passionate
for the thing I would say well this
isn't fun this is kind of boring I'd
rather be doing something else
so maybe I'll just go do something else
and I'll hop on Facebook or Twitter or
whatever and do something that's sort of
passive but anything that's inherently
passive generally isn't meaningful and
turning in terms of doing deep work and
I realized like well wait a minute the
heart the hard work that's actually what
part of what makes it meaningful and
that's when I have to Drudge through the
drudgery and so there are four words
that it changed the way that I thought
about writing was by a writer named
Donald ray Pollock he reads from great
novels what was called the devil all the
time and he turbo Ohio and we met at
this random Thai place in Chillicothe
Ohio and he said sit in the chair I sort
of looked at in what do you mean he
looked at me again he goes sit in the
chair because I've asked him about
writing and like how do you do how do
you make these these novels they're so
beautiful
that's it sit in the chair you have to
be willing to sit down and do the work
and for me it meant setting my alarm an
hour earlier when I was in the corporate
world instead of getting up at 5:45 I
got up at 4:40 for every morning spent
one hour sitting in the chair didn't
worry about word count page count
whatever I set there and did it
invention one hour turned into to two
hours turned into three and that's still
sweet spot two to three hours for me is
it's great you still want to leave
something behind for the next day as
well and for me that's that's drudging
through the drudgery and still now fifty
percent of the time I want to put my
head through the frickin wall but the
other 50% of the time it's like one of
the best feelings in the world
yeah I think for me it's um it's really
focusing on you know why I want to even
dig into the drudgery I mean you know
we're on tour right now we're doing 42
cities is here right let me go back
further we did a hundred cities in 2014
it was a blast plague if I could do it
all over again I would totally do
deliver again it was really hard work
like it was unbelievable being in this I
mean I have a whole new appreciation for
bands who toured like do 200 shows David
Sedaris will do over 200 shows a year
like it's unbelievable but get clear on
why you want to even put the effort in
because you know if it's like I wanna
play guitar because I want to be like
you know Jimmy Page and I want to you
know be an excellent guitarist but
that's I mean that's the reason I guess
but like that's not a very good reason
you know so it get clear on on why you
really want to what you really want to
dig into the drudgery the other thing I
would say too is like don't focus on the
big picture and focus on the little
things every day
My partner Mariah right now he's also up
there with Bex
Sam Ryan she's such an awesome partner
like I cannot believe like how much she
supports me going on the road what I was
going to say about her is she is going
through this coding school right now
she's got to spend like six to eight
hours a day and like sometimes I look at
her computer and it looks like she's
hacking into the matrix or something
like it it's pretty crazy and yet like
to get her to come out on this tour I'm
like hey you want to come out on tour
and she's like I got school like I you
know how much I'm gonna be able you know
the work on my on my on my programming
and coding and I'm like ah come on you
know
but she's to make a time for it and you
know what she focuses on everyday just
like learning something new
getting through I can't tell you how
many times she is like just you know
making us feta cheese oh I can't believe
you know I can't get this program to
work or I can't get played a little
Arthur mean yeah I remember that
no that's the Millennium cases function
I can't get this function to to do this
certain thing and and you know what like
an hour later like she will figure it
out or maybe it's the next day but like
just going from point A to point B she
is learning something new and then she
starts over point A to point B and you
know what I can tell you like in the
last four months and she started this
leaps and bounds better than you know
obviously when she didn't know anything
and in the next four months she's going
to be even even further now if I was
like on her every day and I'm like well
when are you going to be employable when
are you going to be able to code for a
company you know I mean that would be
what a what a bad way to look at it
right instead of focusing on that big
picture instead of focusing on the what
am I going to sell my best album what am
I going to have that best-selling book
it's focusing on just growing a little
bit every single day and all those
little growths they add up to a huge
growth I have a thought let's hear it I
think that most people overestimate what
they can do in a year and underestimate
what they can do in a day you know work
works and consistency will rule the day
you know mountains are not moved in a
day but in my experience my own personal
experience and in the experience that
I've had interviewing over 300 people
for the podcast and the high performers
that I happen to surround myself in my
life they will all tell you the same
thing and they will tell you that they
show up every single day to pursue that
thing that gives their life meaning and
purpose they do it irrespective of how
they feel about it
and it is something that is not
necessarily fueled by the quickly
burning flame of passion but the more
sustainable fuel of purpose and meaning
and intentionality right so if you want
to go to the Olympics as an athlete if
you want to write a book if you want to
you know become an entrepreneur startup
whatever it is it's what you are doing
in that day in that moment what choices
are you making about how you're
allocating your time to make room for
pursuing that thing that's going to move
you forward and unfortunately we're
mired in a culture that has really
heralded the lifehack as the answer for
all of our problems how can we shortcut
our way to you know immediate success
how can how can I become the next
Instagram or whatever it is and the
truth is is that the people that become
successful in the thing that they are
pursuing are the people that are not
trying to find the shortcut but are
actually embracing the journey the long
journey ahead of them and by not
avoiding that and not resisting it I
think that you will have a better shot
at actually moving your life in the
trajectory that you desire as often
that's good that's what I meant
so real quick rich you you were on you
were on the precipice of a heart attack
standing on your stairs and you didn't
decide like well I think I'm just going
to go out and try you know a 5k today
right what what what were the initial
steps because it all feels like drudgery
at some point but we don't have any
momentum what were some things at the
beginning where you're like at least I
understand in the direction now I'm
headed I've been headed in the wrong
direction I need to turn around and not
sprint in the other direction I at least
need to turn around and start going that
way how did that manifest for you well
it manifested initially by by delving
deep into you know who I am you know to
not get to new agey about it but it was
really about trying to trust and follow
my heart you know the gentleman here who
asked the initial question what I
gathered from his question was really a
struggle with trying to figure out like
what it is that is most important or
meaningful and where can he find that
value and I think it's an internal
journey right I didn't have the answers
to any of those things but I knew that
there were certain things that I really
enjoyed doing with my time that I hadn't
been doing you know simple things like I
love how the Sun feels on my shoulder
running on a trail at dawn you know that
doesn't cost me money
you know I mean I was like I'm going to
start doing that you know and the more I
started making choices that allowed me
to do those things that I loved lead to
opportunities lead to other doors
opening so it wasn't like I had this
ideal like I'm going to be an ultra
endurance athlete and I'm going to start
a podcast I'm going to sit on stage
that's still more with the minimalist
you know it's just like you know what
I'm going to go for a run you know and
the more I started to trust my instinct
regardless of what the chatter of you
know friends and family or whatever you
know that that like echo chamber of
feedback that feedback loop that might
not necessarily be guiding you in the
right direction trying to like remove
myself from that I really trust myself
and but - but first that requires that
internal journey of making sure that
your
instincts are Li are true right that are
leading on the right place and you have
to really clean house you have to like
do that mental emotional spiritual
inventory for yourself so that when that
impulse arises you can trust that as
being the right direction for you
and so for me it was just a long journey
of on a daily basis trusting that and
and believing that this would lead
having faith honestly that this would
lead me towards something that would
help me answer those questions and all
that time alone you know running and
training helped me really wrestle with
and and get a grip on trying to define
my own value system and what was
important to me so I think it's about
creating space you know I would have I
would be suggesting to you them to to
meditate every morning try even if it's
five minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes that
internal journey is what is going to
answer those questions for you for you
you know when we are in the green room
in you said something that really stuck
out to me about how you were addicted to
the wrong things in your in your early
life addicted to working does the 80 90
hours a week alcohol and other things in
how you were essentially able to find
better addictions and it's funny because
I think about that word addiction and
it's such a such a pejorative but we're
all addicted to something who doesn't
think they're addicted to something I
will prove you wrong right now I mean I
was really hoping to prove someone wrong
a good monk is gonna stand up we've
actually had that and where was that
where were we
Portland oh yeah we're in Portland
Oregon yes and a monk stood up and he
got off on the my egos are you telling
me I have to become a monk to be a
minimalist
yeah well even a monk he's addicted to
oxygen we don't have oxygen he's dead
we are all addicted to something I'm
addicted to coffee and I guess what I'm
trying to say is is you know a choose
your addictions wisely but be addicted
to good things I think addiction is the
wrong word for that I mean the
definition of addiction is something is
a habit that's that's damaging your life
right so so maybe we could we could you
know figure out a different word for it
but you know where where do you want to
direct your energy we all have
compulsions we're all I think you're
right like I think this our consumerist
culture is fueled on addiction you know
we are addicted to accumulating like in
you know that it goes down from there
right so I think on some level you're
correct
we all fall somewhere on that spectrum
of addiction for me though I have to be
very wary like am I is my relationship
with you know fitness or these other
things that I do is that an addictive
relationship or is that a productive and
appropriately balanced relationship
because if it becomes addictive then you
know my marriage starts to slide and
suddenly I'm not with hanging out with
my kit you like my life will fall apart
right so I can't I can't have an
addictive relationship with the things
that I'm passionate about but I can have
an engaged and meaningful relationship
with those things does that make sense
it does beautiful before we get to the
next question for those folks who listen
to this at home if you have a comment or
a tip for any of them any anyone who
asks a question of that you give us a
call for zero six two one nine two seven
eight three nine and we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode Ryan do you know what time it is
blind it's time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round yeah this is
where we answer questions usually uh
they're really tweetable answers and
like we have a week to put this together
but now you're going to ask it live on
the spot so we try to do is we'll
maunder on a bit and give you something
wrapped up with a nice little bow so
you'll get a regular answer but
hopefully we'll give you something tweet
to go home with you can share on social
media if you like we're at the
minimalists on Facebook and where else
are Instagram and Twitter jess is around
here somewhere
jessica williams handles all of our
social media and she does an outstanding
job with it
jessica williams ladies and gentlemen
yeah she'll be back at the the merch
booth taking photos and stuff after work
so stop by and say hi to Jess
howdy what's your name I am a question
yeah a lightening save and lighting
question I'm good with that one Pippin
is like I'm bipolar and I totally
understand that your mom is bipolar but
if we can minimizing manic spending or
manage anything because I feel like as
far as like bipolar is misunderstood
it's already stigmatized when people
associate mania with trivial things they
don't understand the depths of what
mania does to a person their family and
relationships so I like to tell people
it's bipolar people we're just like
connoisseurs of every emotion or hashtag
lifestyle our emotional engineer
connoisseurs of every emotion man that
is a great Twitter bio speaking to
speaking of life like the lightning
round
Tippie statements that is perfect thank
you for that and then also my question -
maybe you can wrap it up in a bow today
sounds like you guys can relate with me
a fun for a lot of emotional trauma and
for me I think a lot of people when it
comes to trauma I think winning some is
minimalism unpacking our items also it
brings about like not just as the
feeling of having much stuff to kind of
have social status but it's like a depth
of emotion of having nothing you know
what I mean especially me like I've had
no food so like I know that I will by
saying sometimes in a copious amount of
things that I don't need because I feel
like I need to be able to have for
myself any not for someone else so like
how do you like as adults reconcile that
like having parents that let you see
those situations and like as you're
unpacking your parents stuff it has to
be pretty like hard for you you know
I mean a different level of of I would
say like attachment to someone who is
like always had something and maybe they
just bored or they just accumulate items
or it's a serious like you have this
like deep set fear that like if you get
rid of these things you're just like
ungrateful or you just have this like
ruminating thoughts that that are
probably not actually true but it's just
how you you learn to survive I get what
are you afraid of for me I'm afraid that
like I can't I'm on the oldest so I'm
the favorite that somebody I've always
my role in my family's I solve
everything so I'm afraid that if I don't
have enough I won't have a solution does
that make sense so for me my fear is
that that I won't be effective but my
parents can't rely on me that my
brothers and sisters can't look to me
that my friends or my job like I feel
this need to make sure that I can take
care of everyone and even in my job
that's what I do I take care on the
lifestyle engineer I take care of
everyone's life and I make sure that
they if they need their car sighted if
they need their plants water I do that
for them and that for me is very it's
very important because it makes me feel
successful nice to be in control yes
yeah me too I'm a total control freak
I'm a total control freak I I get I get
where you're going oh here's a pity
answer for you crafting the tweets
sometimes letting go of control is the
best way to regain control
oh yeah it's sort of a rap battle but we
don't it without rapping and so yeah you
get to determine who wins this Brian get
him in and then we'll move on the ridge
she's got the longest time to create
something Pippi
are you ready go for it do it dude I
would love some more time I'm not going
to give you that much time this control
is an illusion
[Applause]
I'm just going to ramble on for a little
bit until until I'm home with 140
characters um I can buy you some time
thanks man no well I guess well I am NOT
someone who has to be in control all the
time like I feel I feel like control is
an illusion I've felt that way ever
since as the SWAT team was taken in our
door in the eighth grade I was I mean I
never had I've never had control and any
time I thought I had control I still you
know like kind of [ __ ] would hit the fan
you know and you were enlightened early
yeah I guess so um man uh give me can I
take a five-minute break here Mike no I
guess what I would say is that it even
if even if you were to get as much
control as possible like you're never
going to have 100% control so I'm still
rambling still rambling you're never
going to have on a percent control it's
impossible I mean the big one might hit
right now it would be an honor to go
down with all of you in this beautiful
theater but but you know what what I'm
saying though is is that
I think I got something uh pursuing
control will eventually teach you that
you have no control thank you thank you
I'll take it
and you'll suffer while you're doing it
yeah yeah it's so true yeah I think that
that is true me so I was thinking the
other night it was a really good example
we were in Los Angeles and I was feeling
outstanding before the event like true
everything was great like we had a
really good meeting with Netflix right
beforehand working on something else I
[Music]
had to work you all seen our documentary
well ladies and gentlemen the Italian
stallion himself Machiavelli director of
minimalism he's here tonight right up
here you truly can't thank Matt for the
documentary leg it's funny people be
like great documentary I'm like I know I
was in Italy that's the guy who made it
all happen yeah for sure so anyway we
were there in Los Angeles and like we
had a great gas Rob Bell was there and
we had an amazing like musical act it
was a local act opening up called run
river north and I'm so excited for all
of it and and I realized that I my
expectations for the night were really
high so this is the just echo what was
going on a second ago I think when we
start having these high expectations we
set ourselves up for failure and we want
to have control over everything then
that is like the unreachable expectation
and we had an outstanding event but in
my mind like there were three things or
four things like really trivial small
things that only I noticed that went
wrong and I'm just like kicking myself
and so I guess my other pithy answer for
you would be lower your expectations and
raise your standards
I'm going to apologize to the line
because we literally have thanks for the
question she wins it was like a 1 but
what I thought this was supposed to be a
lightning round thank you I would
apologize to the line because we have
time for one more one more question at
this point I know all our respective
time I promise to give you a hug
afterward yes and if you if you tweet us
I promise you will get a pithy answer a
turn or yes you could call into the to
the podcast you can now you can even
send us like a voice recording you can
like write it all out and read it but
like we will get to it at least on the
podcast for sure yeah podcast at the min
most black column is the email address
we got time for one more save the best
for last what's your name brother Joe I
have you know I guess I really relate to
you guys because you could take that mic
out man I'm sure it'll be ok
never guess because I was making a lot
of money and buying a lot of things that
I need
you know I still have CDs and DVDs has
never opened I've never worn and so this
is this is great being here great many
guys and listening you guys but I got
kind of a fun question I think it is
anyways now what movie would you say he
likes the most that kind of relates to
what you know you went through because I
think of stuff like Fight Club and
office space and I know you've mentioned
that in your podcast at times which one
is líderes and I suppose
I'm pretty sure there's like there's
just there's actually just me and rich
on stage right now and therefore this is
just a figment of my imagination right
here I'm not even real man how do you
know it's not the other way around
oh no we can't just we can what's not
real you just ruin the next Netflix
special the plot was right in so
actually yet I think I think Fight Club
and office space there's like this
marriage between the two and you get our
lives in a way are there any movies to
stand out I've never been in a fight in
my life man that's not true we used to
box in high school yeah that is a count
all right all right well yeah but I mean
there's one movie that stands out and
it's back to the control thing it's
moving probably virtually no one in this
room has seen it's a movie called August
and has a actor named Josh Hartnett in
it and it was like a little indie film
and it takes place the the month before
the well the months before 9/11 and the
month before the markets crashed and
everything and sort of the tech bubble
but you had this guy who was thought he
was all-powerful he was running his
little tech company called I think was
called landshark
I think I was supposed to be like a
MySpace or Facebook or something and he
was running his little fiefdom but then
when you step far enough away you
realized that like he looks like he's in
control but he's really not and
everything around him is spiraling out
of control and it was so much like my
life for everything if you look closely
it it looked it sort of looked the shiny
facade but you step back you realize it
was just that it was a facade and I
didn't really have control and
everything in my life needed to change
and so yeah I mean that was a movie that
stood out I thought it hit the answer
for you though yeah I don't have a hit
the answer um if no one had seen I guess
is the documentary on the movie but if
no one has seen Tom Shadyac Siam go
watch it yeah everyone's right though
that was it was so funny because like as
Josh now we're having these
conversations I believe it was it was
right around the packing party either
right before right after but that movie
came out and it just like affirmed for
me like I'm sure for you Gary like you
heard Josh and I and you're like oh yeah
like these guys like okay like this I'm
not crazy like that's what Tom Shadyac I
am did for me it's like okay I'm not
nuts so yeah I don't know if you've seen
that or not man but I am is unbelievable
he did Tom Shadyac did another movie
called I think it's happy I like I am
better but they're both great movies
absolutely knows this well you know what
Josh so know what the Josh I'm like dude
let's read about the packing party and
so like you know I put journaling for
the 21 days and like you know Josh does
a very good job of like taking my words
and making a lemon sound good or and we
had like that packing party story but
then Josh had written a few essays and
one of them I don't know if this is why
you thought a Fight Club but one of our
original essays on the website was about
how Fight Club was about minimalism yeah
and there's I totally agree man like
there are so many just like great
takeaway lines and that if you are 25
quotes from that movie that are about
minimalism that you've scared of in most
calm /fc it's really going Richard about
you there any movies that really really
stood out that have either highlighted
or changed things for you as it relates
to minimalism or just in general in
general and like I mean Fight Club is
like my favorite movie yeah it's like
it's incredible and I think it is a
perfect it is the manifesto of
minimalism and the allegory in that
movie is really profound and it's very
primal as well
so I think that's appropriate I also
like to I am I mean for those that don't
know Tom Shadyac was one of one of the
most successful directors in Hollywood
literally you know had everything that
you could ever possibly imagined and
walked away from all of it you know and
it's it's so it he's he's the story is
beautifully told in his eloquent style
and it's very moving so I would
definitely check that out beautiful all
right well let's move on real quick to
our added value segment of the show so
where Ryan and I usually just recommend
something Ryan you have anything that's
added value to your life on this trip
yeah man Mariah and I we just ate at
this place called Rome it's
it's like right up here on I figured
shoe this is that's the one you're
putting as a ceiling yeah I know it's
great and it's um it's like totally
local I love this because it was like um
it had like you know here's a hamburger
and then like the farm it came from
here's the free-range turkey burger
here's the farm and came from it was
just I mean you can just tell they're
very deliberate with their with their
sources but yeah if you haven't been to
Rome go eat there it is freakin awesome
and you can go there and get like a big
double cheeseburger or you can like get
a salad and get to my turkey burgers on
top so hello or or you could go there
and get a nice vegan salad but you
seriously can like they have it's like
food for everyone it's great and Mariah
got lover she has so many allergy so
like it's really important we find we
find good food for her because I mean I
feel so bad when go out to eat she's
like you know what is in this what is in
that and I'm like like if she doesn't
ask these questions like there will be
repercussions and they had like this
amazing amazing like just like hot
vegetable mix that she'll like a turkey
burger on top oh but it was it was all
good although it was great and they
totally do it vegan options there those
if I may those turkeys are totally vegan
I'm sure that's the first time you've
heard that we're going to talk after the
platter
I'm going to be really cliche and and
just just because I I love their coffee
so much it bluebottle was like one of my
favorite places in the country and I
order it when I'm back in Montana even
even though Ryan and I own a coffee
house down in st. Petersburg Florida
constantly ordering Blue Bottle coffee
because I really dig it there's a bunch
of other also coffee shops here too but
I tend the frequent bluebottle in fact I
was just there right before we came here
Richard got anything now we had a great
day today but the thing that has brought
me the most value is just being here
with you guys man how oh such a
privilege and an honor to be sitting up
here with you guys everybody give these
guys a hand
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible thank you so much brother
it's really an honor to share this page
with you I'm grateful that you here real
few things are going on real quick we do
a quick segment called right here right
now we talked about what's going on
lives of the minimalists we're in the
middle of 40 city tours called the
lessons now tour and that's where we are
right now we've still got about half of
that less you can go to less is now calm
we're headed all over the country all
over Canada we're doing the Midwest or
they're going to be out east down sell
internationally I will be in Texas and
oh that's a fun joke we love you Texas
red with three stops over there
be aware we're all over the country if
we're not coming to your city we're
within a couple hours drive of wherever
you are in most places and so if you
want to see us go to lessons now calm
you can find all the dates theaters
tickets all that fun stuff
also we refuse to clutter our podcast
with advertisements so we could use your
help we're trying to build a new podcast
studio and also to get a full time
filmmaker so we can turn this into a
video version but also we want to make a
bunch of new video project so video
essays live stream we found that the
documentary resonated with a lot of
people so we want to do many
documentaries and a bunch of stuff that
we can put on
I'm employed elsewhere but because we
don't make any money from the podcast
whatsoever we could use your help if you
want to contribute you can just go to
the minimal com click on that donate
button at the top we just set up a
patreon page so that you can donate yeah
thank you
oh you can donate a buck or two per
episode and if you do that it's going to
help us does none of the money goes to
me Oh Ryan it goes to build that studio
weightless I need I needed two nicer
black teachers I thought we were going
to get minimalist amendment a minimalist
helicopter it also allows us to pay
podcast Sean a full-time living wage and
this is one of podcast shot this is what
it was not for Sean I don't know what
would we do so if you want to support us
just head on over to the minimalist comm
and support Sean and his family it helps
us build a studio and do a bunch of
other cool meaningful creations that we
get out to you ladies and gentlemen Sean
the man of many hats most important I
want to thank you all for being here
Ryan and I will be outside and about
about 20 minutes or so and you know what
you decided to spend some money so that
we could rent out a great theatre and be
here but you spent more than just money
tonight you spent your time and
attention those are two most precious
resources and we want to thank you and
acknowledge you for being here tonight
if you leave here with just one message
we hope with this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thank you so much hi my name is Kate and
I am from Reno Nevada
I recently listened to your family
podcast and I had a tip regarding Ella's
birthday presents and kids birthdays and
Christmases in general while you were
trying to practice minimalism we did a
couple of birthdays and Christmases and
tried to ask people not to bring gifts
but of course family members always want
to give you stuff and honestly I usually
let the kids play with it for a wee
or so and it all ends up with a thrift
store anyways so this last year we
decided to start adopting animals and we
have an animal Ark that is just outside
of renown that rescues and rehabilitates
wild animals and animals that have been
raised in captivity and whatnot but you
can donate to them you can pick which
animal you want to adopt and you can
donate to them throughout the year so we
adopted a wolf and at any of our kids
birthdays we now put on the invitation
that if they'd like to bring a present
if they'd like to donate money to the
wolf they can we also adopted an
elephant I think we actually just said
the elephant for a day from the elephant
sanctuary which is located in Tennessee
we adopted an elephant for my mom for
Christmas a couple years ago so now
since she loves elephants she gets a
monthly email newsletter about how her
elephant is doing and she really loves
that so that could be a great way to get
people involved they feel happy giving
you something and then they can continue
to follow that animal online hi
minimalists this is Paul corn from
Cardiff in the UK and just in response
to Tracy's comments on episode 85 I
thought it was a very good good advice
to share regarding the tables and
surfaces and how they can easily
accumulate clutter and I've just started
trying to minimize basically and things
are going pretty well so far and the one
thing I find myself really kind of as
found is accumulated clutter and
unnecessary items are boxes in the past
I've kept a lot of kind of decorative
boxes tins packaging that sort of thing
which can be visually or statically very
very nice very interesting but I found
that that's almost been
well I think lecture said a magnet for
the clutter and necessary items so I
wanted to share that and maybe for
people like myself who are starting to
look to minimize their possessions and
their lives
another tip maybe watch out for surfaces
and four boxes tins and similar similar
things hey Josh and Ryan this is Haley
from Arkansas I feel like I have noticed
a lot of other parents that are trying
to get into this minimal or something
having trouble knowing what to do with
all of the crafts and drawings and
things that their children bring home
from school and I recently discovered an
app called TP that's K e EP one and it's
really neat you can take a picture of
whatever the item is and you can write a
description of it you can put when it
was created and where and then you can
also record a video of your child
describing what the drawing is up and
you can separate it to all your children
so you have a different folder for each
child and then you can share all these
things privately with whatever family
and friends that you want to the app
costs about $15 a year but that seems
really reasonable to me to cut down on
the stuff that you're saving and then
there's another app or a website called
keepsake and that so does it Q so it's
qu e EP s a ke e and it's a service to
help with recording memories of your
kids kind of in place of the baby book
if you
wanted and you can go in and enter your
child's information and they will text
you questions as frequently as you want
to pay for the free services once a week
but you can have it every day for his
child if you want to and also text
pictures if you want to so they text you
a question and you reply back and then
they save it and then you can just log
in and look at your book if you want you
can print it out if you desire to at
some point but that's another way that
parents can cut down on some of the
clutter that comes with the thin parts
of piercing
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you things that to me
I have a little singing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you
were fine without it
[Music]
every little singing that you got a hand
every little scene that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand though I
bear that you be fine without so Jo
[Music]